when did you start writing movies
i was in acting school and i was feeling
just a little like i wasn't quite
connecting to any material i felt like
there was more in me that was maybe
even outside of acting and so i just
started writing
i just i had a friend who was writing he
recommended that i download
celtics you know c-e-l-t-x it was free
at the time i'm not sure if it still is
but i was like oh excellent so i you
know went home and i started just
drafting up
pretty much the worst stories we will
ever read today
they were not that good they were very
uh boilerplate you know they were very
cliche
and full of just regular common tropes
um which is totally fine because that's
that's good you you want to like start
with that and
and run with just whatever is speaking
to you and so that's what i did i
started writing that must have been
i want to say like four or five years
ago now
um and really i've been writing ever
since i really have always always loved
writing
screenwriting was new for me but i used
to try and
write you know in standard like novel
format
all the time because i love i love
telling stories like i hope one day
to be a master storyteller and
that would be my greatest gift to be
able to create stories that
you know they reach out through time and
space to people
and and maybe can inspire or excite and
draw emotion and touch people you know
from around the world and um
yeah i really hope to just become a
better and better storyteller as i
keep writing so you're taking this
acting class
it's l.a based yes okay valley-based
and you were going back and writing and
you said you were writing these very
common tropes
it was yeah what were they well i mean
it was really even the entire
storyline was just very cliche so i
would say i can i can give you one of
them it was um
this couple who are in an uber share and
they fall in love but the guy doesn't
like her and she does not like him
and but then she somehow like somehow
some property you know
gets swapped between them and they have
to meet and they realize that they
do have some things in common ah twist
and uh and then they fall in love and i
had this whole scene that i wrote where
she
or he's like running down sunset to like
catch the uber that she just got in
i mean i'm sure in some world that
that's actually a good script like
in the hands of uh you know aaron sorkin
i'm sure it could be a brilliant he
could take that
what i just announced to everybody and
say okay i'll run with this as a
freaking challenge and make something
great out of it
uh you know as a project writer i did
not run with it in a very
advanced way it was very like
boilerplate
and so did you feel it was boilerplate
or did other people
give you feedback on it that was one
where nobody really
read my work then but you know you you
kind of read your work a little bit
later and you're like oh i
just why did i do this this is just so
you know you see it a lot
you see it often and furthermore with
with my writing i'm always a little bit
harsh on myself as i think everyone
really should be especially if you
intend to be the one putting it in
production or or if you're going to
pound the pavement and try and sell your
script
be honest with yourself is this a good
piece of work are you ready to
pound the pavement and try and sell the
script or are you yourself committed to
fun you know finding financing
assembling a crew
putting this into production like are
you going to make it and if you are
let's start from a really solid
foundation with a script you know
everything is built off of the script
so that's where that's why i'm a little
bit harsher with my my critique of my
scripts because
i now i'm on the other side of that
looking glass i know exactly how much
work goes into it how much effort time
money and that stuff is not like time is
priceless you know you can never get
that back so you really need to be
building from an extraordinarily strong
foundation of the script
how do you know you have a good movie
idea it's a great question
i think everyone wishes they knew the
answer
um i don't know if you can ever know it
but i know that you can feel that we all
know that that feeling that nugget of
excitement
inside of your chest and you see it
clearly and you're going
absolutely absolutely i can feel it now
that's
that's more intangible that's me just
talking about passion and inspiration
but if you are looking for you know
maybe you're building a marketing deck
or something like that you need to like
show financials like facts that this is
a good idea
i think the best thing you can do is
look for comps you know look for
comparable films and
budgets and try and figure out okay this
is
this is slightly similar to what i'm
creating
did they have a really clearly defined
marketing strategy
is it is it clearly articulated to the
end viewer what it is that i'm telling
if the tone is muddled your characters
aren't defined you might want to go back
and like
start you know fine-tuning that but if
you can really
you see your character so clearly you
see exactly what the tone is going to be
then you're in a good place you can keep
going you can keep
green lighting yourself to the next
chapter of your of your process
yeah are there other ways that you test
your ideas
for something i like to do if especially
if you're maybe at a
delicate stage of your story where it's
not quite ready for
peer feedback something i like to do is
walk away from the script for a little
period of time you know maybe even like
a month or
if you need to a few months because you
have no idea the clarity that you'll get
it's
like hitting the reset button and then
when you go back to that script you're
reading through it
you get to see with really fresh eyes
like
okay this is this is pretty great or or
okay this needs a little bit of work but
i see what i did here and i see what i
did here
let's just tighten up these bits and
then this is good to go so that's one of
my little
kind of obvious tricks to do just walk
away from your project really let your
brain reset
watch different genres of film read
different genres of books you know or
whatever
and then go back to whatever it is you
wrote and try and look at it with the
freshest die as possible
what's a film that's out there that you
you wish so much you'd written it like
the dialogue is so perfect
or or even the lack of dialogue just the
just the
show don't tell okay this is gonna stop
so we recently re-watched the matrix
i was on a high after watching that
movie it is the best movie
ever the script is so tight the
characters you're like
and of course then there was the
foreshadowing in this scene and then of
course he's going to do this and this is
and i mean i still i still cry and like
get the get the chills when
you know the helicopter scene and
morpheus and stuff
oh my gosh i was in i was on cloud nine
i wanted to write like a million scripts
after i re-watched that movie
um which i know is really popular maybe
so everyone's probably like yeah duh
it's a great movie
but that that type of film inspires me
for
for days and that's really like that
gives me the boost too to create
every damn day because i watch something
like that and i think
that started out as just someone's idea
um
the wachowskis i don't know but they're
wachowskis they one of them said to the
other one hey how about this
and then just from them kicking the idea
back and forth it became
what it is today like this incredible
film
um that changed a lot of people's lives
and definitely i remember like getting
on vhs and just
popping once the v8 just popped out of
the tv popping it right back in rewind
i'm watching that again
i love that bill okay this is off topic
a little bit but i was at a store and
somebody's like oh
they can help you and they're like neo
can you help her yeah and i was like oh
wow i bet you their mom and dad
yeah because he was young enough to be
that eight you know i bet you that's
what happened
he's the one he's the one to help you
exactly and he was very helpful
he was like well he's the one victoria
how protective
are you with your movie ideas fantastic
question
so um i'm going to share a story in a
moment
i used to write my ideas and then like
you know aaron is obviously my partner
in all of our
writing and production processes and i
would tell him
and you know then maybe later that day
we'd be on a walk and he would just be
chatting you know we're walking around
los angeles somewhere and he's chatting
and he's like talking about the story
line
and i'm going sh there are actors and
writers everywhere and producers
shh like our idea and he he was the one
who told me like listen
yes it is absolutely possible that
someone can steal your idea
but first of all no idea is new like
every idea is you know kind of like
coming from something else
and have confidence in
your ability to create it because even
when we make when we make that idea or
if we ever make that idea it will have
our
stamp on it we'll have our style on it
and if someone else can come by and take
that idea and somehow make it better
than what we were going to do
then good because like ultimately i want
the best story out there
i mean i'm not telling anyone to steal
my ideas please don't but you know if
if someone does uh come up with a better
version of it i'm all for it
and so that's the like a few years ago
we came up with the idea for have you
seen
the movie freaky within spawn okay
so we came up with that idea however
many years ago
and i loved it i loved the idea i was
like okay we've got this serial killer
and he's locked away in this jail and
there's this like school field trip
where the city all these
like high school kids come and you know
maybe there's some like earring that the
one girl is wearing it's very much um
freaky friday meets but but instead of
the to the mom and the daughter it's a
serial killer
swaps bodies with you know like a
teenage girl and that was i mean that
was the idea we
had come up with years ago that's the
exact synopsis of freaky and it's
you know it was just released i think
there was a producer like from the
blumhouse team who made it and
you know starring vince vaughn and i
watched it and when i saw it released
some giant part of my heart was like
that was our amazing idea it was one of
our tentpole ideas because we don't we
didn't have millions of dollars to put
that in production
so it had to like sit in the library of
you know
treatments um so there's like some part
of my heart was like oh
no i love that idea i was just waiting
to make it but then this other
huge part of me that's very realistic is
like of course someone else came up with
that idea and i'm so glad that they made
it and i think it was a really fun
movie i think that perhaps a few of my
details might have
improved it no i'm just kidding but i
think they did a great job and i'm happy
to see it come to life so
um you know i would say for people who
are worried
don't let it stop you from from sharing
certainly
let it keep you open to sharing with
trusted peers and
don't sweat it if you see one of your
synopsis synopsis out there
in film make another one it's okay
there's
a ton of ideas keep going sure and you
know all these ideas are like in
a zeitgeist and it seems like some are
more timely than others
it's just kind of interesting how you
know a lot of stuff that's similar comes
up around the same time
yeah so yeah exactly it's like they
could have been working on that movie
for like 10 years bro i know they i'm
and i'm sure like three other filmmakers
in l.a were like i also had that idea
um so it's good i'm glad to see people
are
coming up with good ideas and and make
making them into a reality
so i just hope that i can come up with
the next the next
fun twisted creepy thriller like that
yeah i think i was hearing that even
when
the writer of the exorcist was still
alive that he would call william
friedkin
and say i just wish that one scene i
wish i could have changed it
this is years later and and
i think that no one's ever you know
totally satisfied and there's always
there's always more to do so oh
absolutely i mean what are they one of
my favorite sayings
not mine but uh
artist's work is never completed only
abandoned i mean that's absolutely the
truth when can you ever walk away from
something you've poured your heart your
love into
when can it ever be done to your forever
liking it can never be done to your
forever liking but you know maybe one
day you need to sell that
beautiful creation and you need to go
ahead and slap the it's done
sticker on it and move it off to the
distribution line and
look on to the next one
you